we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
uh i'm getting more and more emails
voicemails
tweets as my goatee has filled in
still pathetically but it has there are
lots of people who are not pleased with
it take a listen to this
okay david pakman yes
thomas from austin calling
sounding the alarm yeah
we don't need to go into this
kind of goatee phase that i
see happening yeah i'm very
happy about your vitamin d levels
thank you but the goatee
it's not gonna work man you've gotta go
clean shaven looking good
like a news man yeah so listen i am not
a newsman
i am merely an analyst a commentator
so there's no editor telling me i need
to be clean-shaven but it's not going to
last that much longer
my girlfriend has already put in her
complaint about it
um and uh it's not going i think i will
probably do one show with just the
handlebar mustache and then it'll be
gone
i know this is not very important but in
a time when so much is happening that is
extraordinarily disturbing
uh why not talk about one more
disturbing thing which is my inability
to grow
serious facial hair we've got a great
bonus show for you today
i am so glad to see that new england
patriots coach bill belichick
is uh not going to be moving forward
with receiving the presidential medal of
freedom from donald trump very glad to
see it
we will talk about that and much more on
the bonus show
grab a membership at joinpakman.com